now guys in act 1 where do we go to a
middle-class house at 5:00 a.m. and a
loser because waltz in bed with his wife
in a terrible shabby little vinyl
papered bedroom but it's not poor guys
Hollywood usually Hollywood shows poor
people really well they show rich people
really well what they have trouble with
are showing middle class people as they
really live Walter and his wife Skyler
are unsuccessful but they're not poor
Walt sighs he wakes up he throws off the
cover his pajamas are clean but they're
synthetic and cheap he exercises on this
little Stairmaster that's broken he
doesn't give us crap about his life and
now suddenly we see on the wall in this
really looser place a plaque that says
in 1985 nuclear chemistry what does that
tell us remember I said that a hero is
misusing his super power at the
beginning of the story how is Walt
misusing a superpower we don't know yet
but we know he's not using it here
because he's such a loser what happened
to Walter we want to know now when we go
to breakfast
there's the breakfast in the breakfast
nook and we meet his happily henpecked
wife what happens to a woman when the
guy she's with
is a failure what does a woman do
usually if she's with the guy what does
she do well in this case Skyler over
Mother's him she's trying to do
everything she can to help him out she
probably holds his hand where they
watched self-improvement videos at night
hoping he's gonna finally step up to the
plate but this is Walt's fiftieth
birthday by the way and they also get
really angry she's had affairs she's
trying to leave him but she can't she's
tied to the guy she's gonna be tied to
him for seven years it says also his
50th birthday and she gives him a plate
full of soy bacon that spells out 50 and
he looks at and goes what is this stuff
it's not real and she says it's soy
bacon you won't take
the difference everything about this
scene shows us what that he's a loser
and she's trying to not be panicked and
disappointed at what a loser he's turned
out to be
she's also visibly pregnant so the bacon
is plastic the world is plastic and now
here comes their son Walt Jr who is
disabled that's not an accident he comes
into the room on his crutches and he is
a great kid but he's disabled and when
Skyler criticizes breehn lady says
there's no hot water again and Walter
and Skyler look down at the table
because what why is there no hot water
because everything in the scene is about
how it's disappointing and so she tells
him to eat the bacon eat the veggie
bacon now they go to the school even the
car he drives is a vomit green Pontiac
Aztek the class disses him there's an
alpha male couple in there that won't
pay attention to his lecture we're still
in the B storyline which is can Walt
take care of his family that's the B
storyline question the answer is no he
cannot take care of his family
not at all this gorgeous couple makes
out in the back when he tells them to
stop they just dissing and then we see
Walt go to his second job which is
working at a car wash and not only is it
working at a car wash but his boss now
tells him Walter I'm short-handed today
go out and do wipe downs Walter now has
to go from behind the cash register to
wiping down a car and guess whose car he
wipes down that gorgeous alpha male
couple from the high school now they
take pictures of him laugh at him for
being a car cleaner and put them on
Instagram oh my god Walter White is
washing cars what why is being
humiliated again and again and again and
it ends with a surprise birthday party
where we see is ultimate humiliation but
we also return to the a storyline what
is it Walt's brother-in-law Hank who is
a DEA agent and by the way guys if you
want to make
and anti-heroes sympathetic surrounding
with bigger a-holes than he is Hank is a
blowhard who has made fun of Walt for
years and today he does the same thing
he steals Walt's beard he says well you
got a brain the size of Wisconsin we're
not gonna hold that against you ha ha
come here buddy
he drinks Walt's beer and shows his gun
to everybody right not subtle the kid
handles the gun Oh dad this is such a
big gun yeah it's a big gun and I give
it to man Walt's just the shrinking
little violet in the corner like he's
been for 15 years while Hank blurry
eights that's the way it's been that's
the way it's always gonna be but now we
return to the a story which is this on
the television why they all watch
there's Hank busting a drug dealer and
there's a pile of cash and Walt who's
been in the corner with his beer slumped
over sees the cash every day why don't
you come with me on a ride-along buddy
get some excitement in your life and
Walt says no I can't do that now we go
back to the B storyline can Walt take
care of his family and in it's his
birthday
so his wife tries to give him a
and Walter can't get an erection he
can't take care of his family he has no
money his wife actually stops in the
middle of the to celebrate the
fact that she won of oz on eBay and
that's Walt's life tiny disappointing
awful and it's over for him but now we
end on the C story when he goes to his
carwash job and he's looking at a
beautiful girl in a beautiful car that's
the life he never had he clutches his
chest and he falls to the ground that's
our C storyline which is his Walt gonna
die
that's how we end the act on that
cliffhanger now when we open on the next
act Walt's getting the news he's going
to die this is what pushes him forward
this is why we have sympathy for him
he's gonna die but he's so disconnected
from his own life that he just tells the
doctor I heard you know I'm gonna die
near so when you've got mustard on your
collar he goes home and now he does
something surprising we're seeing him
reveal a new facet of himself we've
never seen he's a liar but now back at
the car wash when Bogdan orders him to
go out and do wipe downs again we're
seeing him change
he tells Bogdan to go screw himself
knocks everything off the counter and
leaves
Walter is changing but he's an addict
here now what is the definition of an
antihero an antihero is someone who
becomes evil for sympathetic reasons
this is why we like him this is Michael
Corleone II and the Godfather this is
Harvey Dent in in in Dark Knight we have
to have sympathetic reasons to like an
antihero we have sympathy for Walt
because we've seen that he's gonna die
now at the end of the Act
he calls Hank and he says Hank can I
come on that right along can I see you
bust some drug dealers Walt is changing
and in act 3 we open with Walt in the
back of Hank's car while Hank makes
racist jokes about the people who are
about to be busted then we see the eyes
busted and as we see Hank bust these
amphetamine dealers Walt looks out of
the car and he sees from the next house
over his former student Jesse jumping
out of a window and a naked woman
throwing his jeans this is the D
storyline and the D storyline here is
will Jesse and Walter become
co-conspirators and as we see Walter
watch Jesse jump in his car
Walter comes on the license plate and
says Captain Crunch and he thinks I am
gonna follow Jesse around Jesse flees
the scene and that night Walter shows up
at Jesse's house and says to him you and
I are gonna cook meth
together and Jesse's like are you
kidding me come on mr. white even my
high school teacher you don't want to do
that well it says either that or you go
to prison cuz I turn you in that is the
new Walter the tough Walter that Walter
were gonna see through the entire
seven-year run of the show he is a
different guy and the D storyline
question will Walt and Jesse become
friends his answer it looks like they're
done it now we end the act not on that
but on a part where it makes the
audience stand up and Cheer Walt and
Skyler take their son to the mall to get
jeans and as they put these jeans on
their disabled son these three big jocks
start making fun of the Sun mummy my big
boy pants they're awful and Skyler sees
it and she wants Walt to do something
about these bullies but what does he do
he leaves the store like a wimp
forcing Skyler to start to say to the
son okay son I'm gonna go take care of
these guys
but as she does Walt bursts in the front
of the store walks right up to these
three guys that are all three feet
taller than him and says come on take
your best shot come on
take your best shot get out of here you
stupid little twits and these huge guys
actually melt away
Walt's suddenly becoming a strong guy
and we're standing up and cheering him
even Skyler is shocked and a little
turned on because this is the new Walter
so we in the act with the B storyline
question Walt I care of his family you
Betty will he's tough he's new guys is
he gonna become a criminal yes but the
secret of great story is to make us
empathize with someone who's doing bad
things
Walt steps in Act four
you